so we've looked upon it something bad
losers don't or whatever it may be but
some of the greatest athletes ever
walking like that you know the man
sitting next to me some all smoke weed
and you know we such huge fans and well
man think you've had me it's an honor to
be here I love Matt man I love what
Matt's doing the first time I got to
meet Matt was at that event at snoops
compound I was great appreciate you guys
coming out that day too
man a lot oh yeah it's a big deal us
athletes and you know whoever can come
out and tell a true story about how this
plant has positively helped them I think
it's important you know yeah I think
that's what you know this space is
missing is just the educational factor I
think there's so many old stereotypes
about what this is supposed to do or
what this does but in actuality there's
been you know and you know athletes who
looked at it screaming the crop and if
the router careers have been several
guys that have successfully you know
been athletes and and smokers and you
know haven't missed a beat and they've
been better for it no doubt so you can
you consumed cannabis during your career
although I started smoking weed at 49
stealing from my dad's plants so seed
stems it didn't matter back then and
then you know hit the pop and stuff
right so it's mostly pop right back yeah
and they smelled but you know since the
inside I smoked all through high school
all through it
my UCLA career and then 15 years in the
NBA was it difficult getting around drug
testing and all that Barry I had to come
like a kind of like a little mastermind
with it in the NBA you get three strikes
had to wither at the width yes and we
couldn't do that though yeah they caught
on to us early so we have to pull our
pants down and like the doctor with
stare attitude
yeah to make sure the pee is coming
right out of the hole so yeah no it was
no game so we you know you just had to
we had to take our shirts off yeah
shorts all the way down that make you
spin around anyway all around the more
intimidate the doctors who's a show bro
one of our we had this big-ass offensive
tackle Tony Packo's he was like six
eight 360 and in Jacksonville and he'd
come out of the drug testing thing so
Percy do you like this man try to look
at my crazy and the guy would be all
full of shame like in the bathroom like
there - yeah my guy was like in the NBA
like when you get in the program they
come to your house once a week you know
I mean so he's coming to the house just
all smiles I'm just like yeah you smile
a little too much to be looking at the
oh my god it's a little weird bro little
[ __ ] weird
so is it is testing for weed random
throughout the NBA season you get four
random tests throughout the season up to
four that's how they kind of tricky cuz
you could be not after your third but up
to four so you get tested from training
camp until the NBA finals are over even
if your team is not in the finals you
still have an opportunity to be tested
so it was just a way you know you live
and you learn and trial and error you
know throughout my career with just
really trying to eat clean drink a lot
of water and stay in the steam room you
know when I'm sweating and yeah you know
cuz I don't really smoke like I used to
summer smoke summer smokers I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm a burn my face off yeah in
the season it's just you know for for
need you know what it which is good and
I made it work nice man that's much more
difficult than the NFL I mean in the NFL
you get once a year right you know and
then you're good to go and I think
that's why they're so strict when you
guys do feel it cuz like if you can't
stay clean for this amount of time for
this one test
you know you know kind of deserve but
within with with the NBA it kind of hit
when baseball hit with steroids and you
know I mean and they know we didn't have
a snowboard problem in the NBA so it's
just like what are they doing or they're
all black they're probably smoking weed
you know what it means so that's when
they started hitting me with the four
random tests for cannabis and it's crazy
because you know once I was in the
program you know there's 150 200 guys in
the program you know and majority are
for smoking wheat whoa that's crazy
what's going on in the program uh you're
getting counseling that they're talking
to you like it's you know like you're
really addicted to a drug which is
dramatic right which is crazy and then
just weekly tests so you could test it
once a week
oh it got unplugged that happens
function we got strict like Olympic
testing though didn't you you guys have
to like the real [ __ ] right yeah yeah
it's crazy it's unfortunate man a lot of
people lost their careers and a lot of
money for you know something that was
really helping us but at the same time
they'll throw any kind of opioid at you
don't care if you drink but let you
smoke a little flower right here you
know you're a bad person in your crazy
mm-hmm you al Steven Jackson you guys
have been really at the forefront and it
feels like something's gonna happen but
your witness when the NBA I think you
know al kind of took the lead with that
because I was still playing why he you
know started his movement but as soon as
I finished I jumped on the bandwagon so
to speak and I really just think it's
through education man and I think that
I'm doing a really cool UCLA cannabis
research program which we're gonna do it
you know kind of from head to tail from
CBD THC the cannabinoids everything it
does for your body and I think the fact
that UCLA is behind that study I think
that's really going to go a long way
yeah all the information and stuff we're
doing we're gonna take two professional
sports you know kind of strengthen our
view and the reason for it you know I'm
not saying cannabis we
for everybody but I guarantee there's a
piece of that plant that's here for
everybody you know some some part of
that plant can help your life in some
sort of aspect so you know we want it
just to be an option you know I mean
like I said though I was taking toward
all shots in the playoffs and you know
that [ __ ]
killing your heart liver everything your
kidneys you know they may do that they
don't care you know but smoke will join
and you know we're gonna find you 25,000
this time in 50,000 next time and then
six gangs would harass me started
finding my hair getting those $25,000
funds left and right moment [ __ ] was
crazy
this time around with the money who be
cool no more [ __ ] you live and you
learn
well the three-on-three League allows
CPD yeah they allowed CBD I think them
in the Olympics if I'm not mistaken the
Olympics yeah they take CBD are like I
said I think that it's a process I think
you know within the next year or two
CBD will be legalized in the NBA Adam
Silver is very receptive and open that's
huge man it's huge because I like I said
it's it's only a lack of understanding
it's what's keeping this so far behind
you know what I mean but that all the
the studies are right here for you yeah
and the benefits right here for you so
like I said I think CBD is a year or two
away and I hope that you know can you
know I I hope within the next three to
four years that cannabis can be
prescribed in moderation such as pills
are you know for for you know for sleep
for pain for focus for all the things
they give us opioids I believe it is it
has to be that thing I said you know
Adam silver is very open and receptive
to sitting down and learning and talking
to people which i think is a great you
know great for the NBA well that's great
I mean I'm glad to hear that because
Roger Goodell definitely yeah it doesn't
give a [ __ ] it's crazy
about too much anything but I think the
MBA and this is all due respects to the
at least kind of lead the way and stuff
you know I mean so we do have kind of
trickle down and everyone else to kind
of fall in line with it hopefully but
like I said that the people that
continue to turn their back on are just
not educated which is unfortunate yeah
cuz it really is one of those things
like the more you understand about it
the more ridiculous you see this
situation you know you know helping kids
with seizures and any kind of little you
know child if a parent is gonna you know
risk their children you know if you have
kids you understand that bond you're
gonna you know you're gonna give your
children something that came on this
plan you must really trust and believe
and have done your education on it like
I said if people are giving children
it's helping children why would you be
such continue to turn a blind eye to its
effectiveness
yeah have you done it what which i'ma
call it with the shamans and all that
you've enema what was it like I want to
do it some what this lady's been trying
to get me to do it I mean I'm interested
in doing them my advice to you to do it
man I can't explain just blew my mind
amazing let me do it again just a new
look at life new look life is really
really this lady's done in 26 times
she's gone all over the country all kind
of that the Amazons to do it but now she
has so she lives out and I met her in
the bear she lives out there behind Napa
on a big property and she has shamans
come to her property and invites her
friends out to do it with shamans and
everything so you don't really have to
go for it it do it really that's the
[ __ ] I can imagine I've been wanting to
do it man
scary but they say whatever comes out
needs to come out you know what I mean
like it has no the same listen I was I
was on the bat I was bad I was getting
high every day at different women and I
was just I was just talking I got really
dark I get really dark so they give it
to me in them suit you got and man when
I took the first hit I never I never
experienced experienced anything like
that before first half's a tall man
these people killed my [ __ ] up killing
me really [ __ ] up I said [ __ ]
different chambers I saw that Aztec [ __ ]
you know me
it seems I need to yeah I need to try
this I'm looking forward to it man I'm
sorry I feel it's kind of drug user
smoking to be high and you could do
whatever give it to me Nansen I fell
right out instantly
yeah how long were you out for I feel
like you went through that much stuff so
[ __ ] with my family were they ready act
I think my family I think what my kids
are all left it's all God is over back
over by fear that you would do it again
though yeah you're scared to death
though but it's alright look you just
get high and enjoy it [ __ ] it's quite
a ride you can't even explain not sure
this lady's word like I said she's done
it 26 times probably more since I last
talked to her but she swears
so a piece of centered very successful
in business you know what I mean like
that like a really good person so now
you kind of just stamped it because I've
been going back and forth asking people
what they thought and some people with
it some people are scared but goes deep
man takes you deep I've done ayahuasca
which is just drawn out longer but you
know the toad is like the spaceship
can't breathe finally let these
[ __ ] into me
it's a dumb [ __ ] after your
stupid [ __ ]
mm but that's what you got to go through
man or the toad takes you I was cursing
myself out Mike you us what are you dumb
they look a [ __ ] you doing this you stop
oh [ __ ] can't help you see your eyes are
open and you still saw everybody but
you're still but you're just going
through some nope my eyes open anybody
stop it stop it stop I don't feel this
way no more [ __ ] stopped it like [ __ ]
man I can't
oh no I went in man I took off
it's not stuff I never could I had never
been the same since nothing the same
well don't you think that's why some
people don't really like weed it's
because it shows you some [ __ ] about
herself
but then also think that people are
afraid of the word high no matter what
it is like that word high scares people
so that's why with Arthur my whole push
within this cannabis space right right
you know the means it's so instead of
like we try to remove the word high from
it and give the educational and the
beneficial sides of it you know being
professional athletes cuz it's always
looked upon as something bad losers
don't or whatever it may be but then you
think about it some of the greatest
athletes ever walked this earth like
that you know the man sitting next to me
yeah some of the best basketball players
greatest football players of all time of
all smoked weed and you know and it's
helped them you know so it's just we got
to educate people mana that's the key is
is educating and then we got to continue
to tell our stories you know I mean we
have to explain to people why we used it
this is what it did for us I mean you
know being an athlete
it's a crazy schedule especially being
you know football or basketball with the
problem in the city believe most of them
addicted parents I mean my parents were
you know my dad was a drug dealer my
parents were drug addicts so I seen it
all and I knew that's why I never [ __ ]
with the coke another other [ __ ] because
it's in my blood to love it you know
what it means that's why when at 14 I
remember my dad was crazy man
he was with such huge fans of you huge
fans you man I'm having like a real I've
met Obama Jordan I didn't rip off
nothing I'll smoke a weak [ __ ]
Mike Tyson right now he's insane you
you've got your own podcast coming out
she's pretty dope you and Steve Jackson
we want to do it myself for Steven
Jackson we didn't want to do it about
life I think too often we pigeonhole
ourselves says in LeBrons on that big
push more than athletes
you know what I mean and everyone always
says when athletes speak out stick to
what you do but we have you know we're
affected by all aspects of society you
don't wear fathers were most of you know
we're business owners we are charitable
cause you know we won't philanthropy so
we're all in also everything that
happens in the world affects us you know
what I mean so I really wanted to be
something where we can speak on whatever
the current issues are and whether it be
politics business religion just really
be open and real because too much too
often people censor themselves and do
politically right but how let's just be
real you know that's check let's teach
this next generation children let's be
real like all this fake [ __ ] that's cool
right now and and pop like that [ __ ] is
not realized let's be real and open with
[ __ ] and me and him do a good job of
talking that way in real life you know
we just wanted to put that you know put
that in the universe and see what it
does
hell yeah brother I'm stoked about right
now you guys have a name yet we have a
man we did a little Instagram contest -
we got to go back and look at those
names okay well you know we're getting
everything right now we're finding the
guy you know producers that I've worked
with and that Jack's worked with and we
just want to do everything from the
ground up people think oh you just go do
a podcast don't on the camera and like
we really want it we know this thing can
be special so we want to do it do some
location we want to travel around yeah
we do want to travel around we do want
to you know be out in the field we want
to you know we want to make it as real
as possible you know we want to meet
people we want to help people we want to
learn from people so let's just be real
about some [ __ ] cuz - like the fake is
winning right now and it's unfortunate
because there's not enough people in a
position with the my home speak or them
faith wins most time good nominee when
people are fake if they won they won
exceptin from a certain group of people
or they want a crown they wanted a good
feeling gonna get money and that's why
the fake is winning cuz people you know
put any things in front of their faces
it's not real you know I mean I think
people like live and die by social media
you know what I mean so most of the time
people on social media are really
flashing money and all this [ __ ] real
wealthy people don't do that you know I
mean so these people are putting on a
show and everyone aspiring to be that
not knowing that these [ __ ] are
training these cars don't really have
that much money you know probably live
with somebody type stuff but they're
showing you know that they're putting on
for the gram so people are chasing
something that's not even real you know
what I mean so you just miss so many
steps along the way when you when you
want that [ __ ] so we just want to be
real with shipment amen brother
[ __ ] yeah man that's it I love that it's
a good person may help people be happy
cuz you know it
I thought the lost you know a close
friend recently it just you just never
know you know when you're like when your
time is up man so why just why be a
[ __ ] why be a hater just man sit back
and enjoy this [ __ ] right we
got real quick you still have the rest
of your life to live you know what I
mean so it's that's what we want to talk
about man we just like I said we're in
tune with every facet and we want to be
able to speak on that that's we're great
you know exactly I don't care how much
money you got right this um there's a
part of that world that we want that
says [ __ ] you you ain't playing you
ain't [ __ ] okay how much money you guys
I don't care it's just that they want
they want to be a part of that success
you running that ball you gonna the main
the last shot they must be a part of
that if you can't do that they don't
care that glory high is so true man
that's so true because he wear that
we've got to hold on to that so long and
then we wound up getting hurt that was
one thing I was was happy about you know
I was I play 15 years I wasn't supposed
to play it means it so be on the house
for 15 years and then win a championship
and be like even though I didn't go out
the way
wanted to I got hurt going into the
plows and anybody that's following my
career knows that like I've always been
out there fighting and doing whatever I
got to do to help win so to go through
that Golden State ride and not get a
chance to play in the playoffs like
really was kind of bittersweet for me
but you know I was still a good teammate
encouraged and stayed ready I just got
hurt and the team was hot and I had to
sit back and watch that's just what it
was but at the same time it was a chance
to win a championship and I'm looking at
the situation like okay I played 15
years I just signed a three-year deal
that year so I still fortunately you
know I'm still being paid until then
until 2020 November but I just thought
like okay well fifteen years man I want
a championship I was going through a
nasty divorce situation with my ex I
wasn't seeing my twin boys much very
much I'm just like you know this is a
perfect time to walk away and just see
what what's next in life you know any me
and I was smarter enough to start
businesses when I was 31 32 I played to
us 37 so things started to flourish all
that championship summer and I'm just
like this is a good time to walk away
and I retire so I didn't want to you
know like Mike just by didn't want to
overstay my welcome you know what I mean
I still love basketball I can still
watch basketball but I just don't miss
it you know it's what I did it was a
small piece of my life but I really feel
like the next step in life is gonna be
amazing because I'm gonna be able to
utilize everything I learned on the
highest level in the NBA for 15 years in
business and meet people and you know
make money with people and just have fun
and it raised my kids and then that's
why it's like I don't regret I don't
look back at the NBA at all like me and
it was really fun it was an honor but
what's next in life is gonna be bigger I
feel like that's great man I [ __ ]
love that mentality yeah I know it's
true you're still getting paid your last
contract yeah until November 12 that is
[ __ ] amazing for you the same time
thing about this I'm so I'm still being
paid by the NBA and I'm being paid to
smoke weed at the same time I love that
[ __ ] yeah the NFL would never do that
the moment we're also being meetings but
that's great that's great I mean I look
back on the NFL I don't I don't miss
playing at all I mean here did you play
six yeah and you're hiding target - yeah
inside me tackle guard yeah and I just
[ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of myself for
as long as I could then I was like I'm
grinding through these injuries this
coach behind me he doesn't give a [ __ ]
and that guy up there who I'm supposed
to be blocking I like that guy like I
don't want to beat the [ __ ] out of him
anymore cuz I used to have that
mentality of just like I'm gonna go
[ __ ] kill somebody you have to you
know but I that's a that's a blessing
man and you I think you you have a lot
of obviously you know maturity about how
you're taken on life after and it's
great for you to jump right into
cannabis like you right canvas is a
no-brainer right I think it like I said
we got to continue you know myself
everyone in here as a former athlete has
a platform we just have to continue to
tell our stories you know we have to I
was fortunate enough to be OH -
executive producer peach for bleacher
report last for 20 call BR for 20 if you
haven't seen it go check it out but it
was all time you know we had five former
NBA players and then six former NFL
players I was on that yeah yeah you know
we are on cameras smoking weed
explaining why this is why this is we
have to tell the world why we use it you
know I mean and then we were able to now
we're able to back it up with you know
such you know universities such as UCLA
and there's other people that are doing
research all the time but like people
are really interesting people who need
to be interested in learning this
because it can help everybody from the
consumers to the economy you know to
everybody so it's just - lets get on it
exactly my shooting and smoking when I
was fighting I when I got in so much
trouble outside of the ring up man I was
always fighting and getting fights
hitting people and stuff that's what
kept I mean [ __ ] mama when my nasty-ass
divorced on my ex and then you know her
her dating my former teammate and then I
had to beat him and I had to beat my
former you know
my friend my friend my shoe I mean so
you got to think like I have to steal
public and then I'm still high stuff to
go and play basketball every night you
know what I mean so if I didn't have we
like I still got in some trouble and
still but if I didn't have leave me I
would probably be in prison man you know
what I mean like we has really saved my
life from just all the [ __ ] I've been
through to just kind of keep me like
come on man you here for a better
purpose you know cuz it just it slows
you down it makes you think a little
more you know I mean get outside your
body and think about the long term and
then stuff so I just think man if it
wasn't for weed who knows no it's great
man talking about divorce I was at my
ex-wife house I was gonna [ __ ] the day
before but we still a divorced you know
we're gonna do it the voice right but
still that's what we do you know
students needing Ramona for that we
still not with anybody so we're gonna
teach other what it is right but one day
I was supposed to go out with toxins
bitch-ass [ __ ] what's that guy named
Brad Pitt now comes up Oh [ __ ] I was
gonna test both of them off but I did
she came and Brad Pitt yeah I think I
heard the word did I hear that you've
all right now you told that I remember
[ __ ] whoopsie [ __ ] I still love this
girl and then two bitch-ass [ __ ] come
up pull up on me and then my car they're
driving your car
yeah and it's Brad Pitt to [ __ ] but for
every member was scared some
[ __ ]
bad come on man if I seen you I would
have made her get out the car just this
[ __ ] we can talk about a comic
or you might remember that's the buddy
system I off you see that stuff this I
couldn't get married
I'm glad you didn't really you guys have
already ran across each other I'm Brad
you never seen Brad I'm glad you didn't
let it go bad she knows I'm coming over
cuz we come over every day she knows I'm
gonna come over that morning why would
she do that open the can of worms my bed
let you live and learn man you got to
live and learn they're probably thinking
the same thing why the [ __ ] did we do
that no that's my thing
- you mean like like dude was staying in
my house with my kids and you didn't
tell me like man-to-man like you want to
you know you're my former teammate
whatever you want to [ __ ] with my ex
that's kind of a sucker move but you
could be a sucker for that but then you
can't stay in the house that I pay for
with my twin boys sleeping next to you
and not tell me that's why that that's
gonna be a problem I people die for [ __ ]
like that
you mean luckily I was a professional
athlete and we just do a couple of hands
but like you die for [ __ ] like that you
know what I mean so it's just like I've
never understood that move you know just
yeah but whatever like I said you live
like it makes you stronger man you know
me and him we're at a cool place now
where you know it's for the kids and you
know they're moving on and getting
married but it is what it is but just
you know just be real talk to me that
that's what this show is about man be a
man you're gonna do something like that
just come talk to him now [ __ ] I should
keep their life miserable [ __ ] stay in
the lane
[Laughter]
I'm good oh [ __ ] [ __ ] head what what
are your cannabis companies we talk
about now how did you feel about that
when was the first time you just started
you were gonna be a pro basketball
played there you go I mean you gotta
talk about that sure you know basketball
was basketball was kind of second nature
you know I grew up a football fan family
my dad played a little bit of semi-pro
and then some some some Park Sunday
tackle football so that's what I grew up
playing tackle football on the street
you know what I mean so I really my
first love was football I excelled in it
you know I was all-american in high
school I think because I just kept
getting taller kept getting taller you
know what I mean and then I realized
like I started obviously I got a little
bit better at basketball so I'm just
like and then I loved started once I
really started looking at basketball
series nothing I fell in love with
Mattie Johnson and I was big and the
Lakers Showtime ship so that's when I
kind of started focusing on I won't we
almost went to school to play both but
then I just focus on basketball and then
just bounce around and I didn't have an
easy career and at that time there
wasn't too many six eight you know
receivers really out this thing would it
probably you could have beefed up to
like 320 and tackle you know just had a
rollercoaster run through my through my
through my career man I had this you
know literally fight you know incline
and it was either me or them and that's
how I looked at my career for a long
time your favorite team favorite team
probably the first warrior team I played
on in 2006 said that we believed him
with me Steven Jackson Baron Davis that
we believed team you beat the Mavericks
but the anyway I said I got to play with
Kobe I got to play with Allen Iverson I
got to play with Shaq mm-hmm I got to
play with mine I got to play with Steph
Curry and clay and Chris Paul and Blake
like I've got to play with a lot of
people then I'm gonna go to the Hall of
Fame man so I played on several teams
but it was a fun house run and it went
by quick and you know I was able to get
the championship and now it's don't you
know I'm off to that next like
early phase in life man you know so it's
I tell you all that they even say to get
back to beginning your question triple
threat is the brand I work with I mean
so I kind of look at it it's at the
basketball cliche but that's gonna be
the name of my my cannabis brand in the
way I look at it like I'm a triple
threat now I'm an athlete I'm a father
and I'm a businessman so I feel like I'm
a triple threat and that's the way we're
gonna push everything I do cannabis I
have a company up north called seven
leaves and they produce all my flour I'm
in partners with them now and you know
just really I've been smoking weed so
long and it's become almost a science
now so you know I've just we want to
make sure we put out the best product
that you know the breast we possible we
want to make sure you're getting super
high off of every joint you smoke of
ours and do right you give the consumers
what they need they're nice man
appreciate it happy hours nice that's
that gushers think it's come down by any
chance to one of the locker rooms and
the teams are playing and pass out your
product I wish I could idea no we
haven't done that yeah we have another I
don't know I'm going to be able to I
don't know I mean I would definitely be
don't get the rooms I don't know if I
could be hand and weed out though they
might be like get this [ __ ] go
for this [ __ ] I think maybe in a couple
years we'll be able to that in the
family room basically handing out we do
yeah once that's ready I'm gonna be the
you gotta come with me hand your stuff
out to but I definitely gonna start
doing it to rapper that's a good idea I
never thought about yeah
yeah that got two guys who know how to
smoke weed come on man yeah
and they'd love for they love weed they
love free weed specimens good week so
yeah it's all good man so it's a great
idea Mike I mean let's just go to the LA
Rams the Lakers let's go to the Dodgers
because it's not legal yet you know I
mean it's legal recreationally in
California but it's not yet a
professional sports oh that's so frowned
upon right but but you know through time
and we're definitely making progress and
I think what we're doing at UCLA is
going to be really big and hopefully it
being a small piece of what you know
over changes you know these outdated
rules and professionals Wars can you
talk a little bit about UCLA stuff is it
specific so what we're doing is you know
I'm looking for you know 10 to 15
athletes they want to donate you know
ten thousand just to kind of get their
names behind and help push this and then
we'll also do a public public round at a
later time but there's no funding for
the benefits of cannabis you know they
don't they don't fund for that so we're
doing outside funding private funding to
try to get you know to get these doctors
on it so we got a I want to say five
doctors if I'm not mistaken in about 15
to 19 faculty members there that are you
know in the efforts you know we're
studying we're studying everything from
THC the CBD head to toe
the benefits from it and then hopefully
at some point doing you know some some
clinical studies and trials where we can
substitute opioid dependent patients
with CBD and THC and just kind of see
how it helps you know their quality of
life because so often you hear these
these stories are how it's helped and
change people's lives so we just need to
continue to we just need to get that
through medical research and then like
how can they say no yeah that's awesome
man yeah I mean that's that's [ __ ] if
you're an athlete and you hear their
scene you want to donate I'm sure Mike's
gonna donate I'm sure these guys are
gonna die
oh yeah brother Mike that'd be dope yeah
I mean we want we want to really want to
push this message man and get this out
and allow professional athletes and
Olympians and everyone really anybody
you know I mean cops need it you know if
you have a stressful [ __ ] life let's
smoke some weed man so they're not some
[ __ ] trigger-happy you know
enemy firefighters doctors everyone
lives a stressful life so the world is
so we're just popping pills popping
pills drinking alcohol let's all just
sit down smoke this we be happy man and
just [ __ ] change the world
like I said a piece of that button
smoking is not for everyone by guarantee
there's a piece of that plant that can
effectively help everybody in this world
I believe that is wrong for sure yeah
here is medicine come on well thanks for
coming man Mike how you like that joint
my wonderful I need to get you on our
when we're done I need to get you on our
Instagram saying that talking to Mike
Tyson right now this is incredible you
have any questions for Mike well we're
here I'm just a huge fan man like I said
oh that's the story I was telling
earlier when I got high and distracted
but and then I feel you fight [ __ ]
quit before you know I just I wasn't I
wasn't with the [ __ ] now but we used
to like my dad is just my table I love
my dad god bless him but he's just a
crazy was always out there and always
fighting and doing everything but we
used to watch your fights man we used to
book macking we used to have a record
him do we would record him too and you
would order my pay-per-view so sometimes
you couldn't really record him because
the pay-per-view wouldn't allow you
sometimes we got him but then my mom
would be pissed because my dad would
spend that $34 and your mother [ __ ]
fights last 50 seconds but now we're
fighting about money like you know he's
gonna knock this [ __ ] out why we
used to watch him we had all your fights
on tape man as I said I had to get a
picture with come on dad it's gonna be
so excited like I said I got a chance to
meet everybody magic Barak Michael
Jordan but I'm [ __ ] smoking a joint
with Mike Tyson that [ __ ] is dope and
I'm not even or not you people know me I
don't really do fan mom's but this is it
for sure family man so thank you for
allowing keep it real right I used to
watch you play you'd have to get beef
with people I said there's something
wrong with this
I wasn't raised I was raised like most
rice going to have a moment you know I
was I was raised to like my dad was he
always taught me to protect my brothers
and sisters you know me so it was so no
people never really [ __ ] with me they
always [ __ ] my teammates you know
means so I would be there to be like my
teammates for my brother so like if you
go if we're gonna no one really wants to
find out the very few who really fight
oh I would have fought you know I mean
so if we're really gonna fight we can
fight I'm not just play basketball you
know me so you're not gonna like pick on
Chris Paul and you're not gonna pick on
Blake and then you know I was with Kobe
and you're not just gonna rough Kobe up
you know me and him had some rough
altercations but once I was on this team
like you're not gonna do that to Kobe
you know I mean I think that's why he
got me and Ron Artest like he was tired
of people roughing him up and we
coursers right so I was just like it was
never I never really wanted to get out
there and fight but like if we're gonna
fight I'ma be definitely be one of the
ones on my team fighting there's no
question about that but let's just play
basketball so a family see I'm Kobe out
in Newport Beach you see the coffee shop
over koba's dope come in Kobe for my
twins 10th birthday I took him out to
Newport and he worked him out so he
knows he got to get worked out by Kobe
and then he sent his my whole au team
shoes shoutout to my little g1e elite
we're the number one ten ten year old
AAU team on the west coast right now so
I got my twins and we got a cooler team
Kobe centum shoes Katie's about to send
him some shoes I was awesome just try to
make you know gets periences for these
little boys so that's what it's about
man I had my fun little run now I want
to you know want to make sure my kids
enjoy life that's great yeah [ __ ]
cool dude Kobe want to get in the weed
game I don't know man I always told her
if we would have want to champion [ __ ]
together here to smoke away we didn't
win that year but I was try to get them
on you get them high that would be
interesting I don't know if you can't
okay this it's not what I wanted that's
the thing like what I want to do is I
want to make it socially acceptable so
guys can really open up and be able to
do that without being judged or lose
endorsements or getting in trouble you
know yeah I mean like people are people
that sit all day and talk and drink or
drink y'all go in the bathroom snort a
line of coke but let let Kobe you know
sit here smuggler joinin people are
gonna want to you know drop him from
Nike or drop him from wherever they can
drop you know that's it's unfortunate so
that's why I want to continue to bring
you know education to this front to make
it more socially acceptable you know
what I mean like I want to get it to
where you know a mom at the end of the
day instead of drinking a glass of wine
she can smoke a joint you know mean why
not why can't she do that to unwind you
know so that's what we need to get it to
for sure man
well [ __ ] dude Mike you got any other
questions come back anytime man when
we're apart I want to do that towed [ __ ]
what you might come back I appreciate
you guys have me I just came to look at
this cool little ramen even though I was
gonna jump on the iPad iPod I mean I
appreciate listen though you never gonna
be the same again I'm ready to not be
you know that's gonna be something for
the better though right yeah that's what
I need I need that you know I've been
through a lot of [ __ ] I need to I need
to elevate for real podcasts are
obviously what's in but people want to
know the story behind the story yes
especially for someone like him someone
like me there's always been such a false
narrative yeah but now you can really
explain who the [ __ ] you are without
having someone else tell your story the
NBA
I did I just wasn't on no [ __ ] with
India like the NBA looks at it like we
own you know you own my likeness because
you pay me you know I mean so I'm always
gonna speak mama I got fun like we're
talking I didn't get the fine you taught
said three million and three hundred big
mines like that you know mean but I'm
talking about like I always spoke my
mind so I got fined a lot for speaking
my mind because like I said it's it's a
blessing to play me don't get me wrong
but before like I'm a grown-ass man you
know I'm a father like no one can tell
me what I can and can't say you know I
mean so that's the way I kind of just
looked at stuff so but I mean I
respected EMBA for the opportunity it
was a dream come true it was great but
like I said it just wasn't I wasn't one
of those you know yes man with them so
kind of like I did in my way but
hopefully respectfully as I could have
and stay true to me that's all you can
do man yeah that's it I think people
love you for that cry so something like
hate me for who they think I am but the
right well it actually get to know me
like yeah we [ __ ] with you because we
really under
stand where you're coming from now you
know any mean and like I said it wasn't
it's for situations like podcast like
this to really be able to give us our
own voice and stop having these other
[ __ ] that really don't like us
tell our stories
did you know pot I didn't but I know
that was your guy he's my favorite
person in the world right yeah right on
my face so he like top pocket man
another country at the African the
children of war do they through it was
Tupac like really that's what I was he's
my all-time favorite and the guy had the
biggest heart in the world do anything
for you you know I get some if he got
mad he was all in right he was just all
in kind of [ __ ] you can stop him he's
mad at you he wants to get Jesus to see
the trip right really a songwriter he
was a trip really a dude really you guys
were close tie though he [ __ ] by me
now I watched everything on him he's
always talking about you somehow you
know I mean like you guys know he was
trying to get in this closet can get in
the club like I'm in this right on it
was the play diem we're in the back and
we left the back door and I was talking
with two guys did you smoke weed yeah
you did laughter Weezy was always
burning right yeah we let him in here
took the mic when India started rapping
in the car was this before he was big
yeah really
and then the next day I know I was in
prison the next thing he came to visit
me know and you guys became super close
yeah man I wish that's one person I wish
I woulda got a chance to me like he's my
anyone who knows me like you can ask any
of my former teammates like I was always
controlling the music before the game
weren't playing Tupac we're not playing
no other [ __ ] cuz I love it this is
how we got to think before we go out
there and play that's what I listened to
me before every gotta get like Tupac was
you start hanging out with some guys for
my for my old a book I'm gonna go that's
kind of strange that's not cool right
yes you know taste and look right
together I knew those guys all my life I
know what they're about you know
that's unfortunate man he would have
been great on the pod oh man he's that
kind of guy he would do things for
nothing being the number guys get paid
for we do nothing wrong right but can
you imagine his knowledge what he died
at 25 26 can you imagine him at 50 you
don't mean he was already so why yeah
man I mean I think the world as a whole
would be different if to part with I
mean rap music would be different but I
really think he had like a cult
following like he could have been
someone that could have ran for the
presidency it really seemed like people
stood behind his words so much you know
what it means so I think yeah still
though come on man still it's to party
you know still so it's just my twins are
10 they know Tupac so it's a little guy
like 125 pounds and that's the maiden
you got to spend some time with him man
yeah that's dope you so yeah well thank
you guys man
another great pod my awesome thing Thank
You Man and I appreciate it man thank
you for having me and the man dude thank
you all right brother
so cool man Kenneth outta here all right
well until next time everybody thank you
for listening subscribe on iTunes and
Spotify subscribe on our youtube channel
and they can get us and they can get us
see with at hot box in with Mike Tyson
yeah I'll be back man let me know when
you guys want me back on back in the
area I use a little right around the
corner from here so yeah yeah this is in
the middle of nowhere
yeah but when I play than when I play
for the Lakers we practice right here
like literally right around the corner
[Music]